we all feel in control of our actions
and thoughts it's what defines us
but as biology and technology begin to
intertwine the question remains could
your brain be hacked the truth is the
brain is an electrical device and
because of this we can interface it to
our own electronic devices in fact
hundreds of thousands of people are
already taking advantage of this with
cochlear implants a type of hearing aid
which mimics sound in the brain through
electrical impulses
however electricity isn't exactly
precise it ends up spreading signals
across many neurons in the brain and in
the case of hearing this can make the
signal muddy or blurry to solve this
problem researchers have found a way to
use light which you can aim and is much
more precise to stimulate the desired
parts of the brain and it's this light
that may be the key to very specific
control over the brain but first these
cells must somehow learn how to use
light as an input source as crazy as it
may seem a harmless non reproducing
virus is used to insert genes in the
desired neurons or brain cells these
genes are taken from other organisms
that use light to survive such as algae
surprisingly we use the same genetic and
cellular mechanisms as them so if you
take DNA from one and insert it in
another it still works these genes
encode for proteins that allow the
neuron or brain cell to act as a solar
cell as a result they react to incoming
light and convert it to an electrical
signal while cells without the new DNA
remain unreactive all we need now is an
optical source to shine light on these
neurons when we want them activated
create this setup within the reward
systems of the brain and you could make
someone happy with the push of a button
stick it into the motor cortex and you
could control parts of movement and this
is exactly what scientists have done
this mouse has fiber optic cables wired
into its right motor cortex which
controls movement to the left as soon as
the light is shot into its altered solar
panel neurons it cannot help but run to
the left its thoughts and actions have
been hacked so what happens when we
begin to stick technology into our
brains on the one hand it may open the
doors to managing physically
debilitating diseases personality
disorders or even conditions such as
depression turn on or off the necessary
cells and voila heck the average person
may be able to integrate this technology
in order to augment their vision
or play video games in their mind and as
we begin to understand the intricacies
of the brain which regions specifically
control which actions and thoughts this
technology will bear even more
significance however the ethical
concerns and risks lurk quietly around
the corner so knowing that your brain
could be hacked would you want this
technology in your brain
don't forget ASAP science now has
t-shirts in both white and black links
are in the description and if you want
the inside scoop on upcoming episode
ideas and behind the scenes check out
our personal Instagram and Twitter
handles and subscribe for more weekly
science videos